عندما تذهب إلى قمة حلف شمال الأطلسي، فإن
القضية الإستراتيجية الكبرى هي أن أوكرانيا تريد
العضوية في حلف شمال الأطلسي
إذا حصلت على
العضوية في حلف شمال الأطلسي. لا أعتقد أنها مستعدة لعضوية حلف شمال الأطلسي
ولكن هذه هي الصفقة التي
قضيتها،
كما تعلمون، وقتًا طويلاً في المحاولة
الحفاظ على تماسك الناتو لأنني أعتقد أن
بوتين كان لديه هدف ساحق
منذ أن أرسل 185000 جندي
في أوكرانيا وكان ذلك هو كسر الناتو،
كان واثقًا من وجهة نظري والعديد من
مجتمع الاستخبارات، كان واثقًا من قدرته على كسر الناتو،
إنه حلف شمال الأطلسي المقدس.  معًا أمر بالغ
الأهمية حقًا،
لا أعتقد أن هناك إجماعًا في حلف شمال الأطلسي
حول ما إذا كان سيتم ضم أوكرانيا
إلى
أسرة الناتو أم لا، الآن في هذه اللحظة في
خضم الحرب، على سبيل المثال، إذا
فعلت ذلك، فأنت تعلم أننا أنا وأعني
ما  أقول إننا مصممون على الالتزام
بكل شبر من الأراضي التابعة لحلف شمال الأطلسي، وهو
التزام قطعناه
جميعًا بغض النظر عما إذا كانت
الحرب مستمرة، فنحن جميعًا في
الحرب، كما
تعلمون أين كانت حرب روسيا إذا كانت
لذلك أعتقد أنه يتعين علينا أن نمهد الطريق
للمسار العقلاني
لروسيا، معذرةً، حتى
تتمكن أوكرانيا من التأهل للانضمام إلى حلف شمال الأطلسي (الناتو)، وهذا ما
حدث عندما التقيت للمرة الأولى
مع بوتين قبل عامين في جنيف.
قال إنني أريد التزامات بشأن عدم وجود أوكرانيا
وحلف شمال الأطلسي، فقلت إننا لن
نفعل ذلك لأنها سياسة الباب المفتوح،
ولن نستبعد أي شخص. إن
الناتو عملية تستغرق بعض الوقت
لتلبية جميع المؤهلات و  من
إرساء الديمقراطية إلى مجموعة كاملة من
القضايا الأخرى، لذا في هذه الأثناء، على الرغم من
أنني تحدثت مع زيلينسكي أتلانتا حول
هذا الأمر،
وأحد الأشياء التي أشرت إليها هو أن
الولايات المتحدة ستكون مستعدة لتقديم المساعدة
أثناء استمرار العملية
وستستغرق الأمر  لبعض الوقت،
تستمر هذه العملية لتوفير
الأمن. الله، الأمن الذي نقدمه
لكم لإسرائيل. توفير
الأسلحة التي تحتاج إلى القدرة على
الدفاع عن نفسها إذا كان هناك
اتفاق إذا كان هناك وقف لإطلاق النار إذا
كان هناك اتفاق سلام ولذا
أعتقد أننا  يمكنني حل هذه المشكلة، ولكني أعتقد
أنه من السابق لأوانه القول بالدعوة إلى إجراء تصويت كما
تعلمون الآن، لأن هناك
مؤهلات أخرى يجب تلبيتها
بما في ذلك إرساء الديمقراطية وبعض
تلك القضايا
الخارجية